experts testifying to congress say
Russian operatives have spent years
spreading false information and
conspiracy theories in the US five
witnesses described Russia's information
war against the US and its allies to the
Senate Intelligence Committee yesterday
testimony claimed that up to 15,000
disinformation specialists sped spread
fake news stories that may have
influenced a 2016 election Russian
President Vladimir Putin was asked about
the accusations yesterday he pointed to
his mouth and said read my lips no Jeff
pjs is on Capitol Hill with the
explosive testimony Jeff good morning
good morning US officials and cyber
experts say the goal of the Russian
information warfare campaign was to
exploit divisions in this country and it
is ongoing with Russian hacking units
continually targeting the computer
networks of us congressmen senators and
others we're all targets of a
sophisticated and capable adversary the
Senate Intelligence Committee learn
details Thursday about the size and
scope of Russia's information warfare
against the US and its allies this is
widespread and a campaign that they're
looking at doing it will drive wedges
between our own political parties and
between our country and NATO former NSA
director general Keith Alexander said
now that the u.s. is aware of Russia's
sophisticated hacking abilities the
country needs to develop a strategy to
confront them if there were a massive
attack we'd have to go back and get
authority to act where if it were
missiles coming in we already have real
soon engagement former FBI Special Agent
Clint wats told the committee that the
Russians may now be trying to cover
their tracks follow the trail of dead
Russians he says there have been a
series of cyber security officials
arrested in Russia and a number of
mysterious deaths around the world
there's been more dead Russians in the
past three months that are tied to this
investigation who have assets and banks
all over the world
many of the fake news stories pushed by
Russian operatives began with real
events last August during an active
shooter scare at New York's JFK Airport
wat says Russian fake news writers added
to the panic we watch social media
trolls and gray outlets pump fake
stories out which ramped up that fear
and what is just as unsettling what
investigators say they don't know right
now about Russian activities in fact one
witness said that there is likely more
disclosures to come because at this time
only about 1% of the information stolen
and Russian cyberattacks has been
revealed Gail thank you very much Jeff